[Music]
more than three thousand years ago a
flower began to appear in remedies in
ancient Egyptian medical texts across
the Mediterranean the ancient Minoans
likely found ways to use the same plant
for its high both ancient civilizations
were on to something
opium an extract of the poppy in
question can both induce pleasure and
reduce pain though opium has remained in
use ever since it wasn't until the 19th
century that one of its chemical
compounds morphine was identified and
isolated for medical use morphine
codeine and other substances made
directly from the poppy are called
opiates in the 20th century
drug companies created a slew of
synthetic substances similar to these
opiates including heroin hydrocodone
oxycodone and fentanyl whether synthetic
or derived from opium these compounds
are collectively known as opioids
synthetic or natural legal or illicit
opioid drugs are very effective
painkillers but they are also highly
addictive in the 1980s and 90s
pharmaceutical companies began to market
opioid painkillers aggressively actively
downplaying their addictive potential to
both the medical community and the
public the number of opioid painkillers
prescriptions skyrocketed and so did
cases of opioid addiction beginning a
crisis that continues today to
understand why opioids are so addictive
it helps to trace how these drugs affect
the human body from the first dose
through repeated use to what happens
when long-term use stops each of these
drugs has slightly different chemistry
but all act on the body's opioid system
by binding to opioid receptors in the
brain the body's endorphins temper pain
signals by binding to these receptors
and opioid drugs bind much more strongly
for longer so opioid drugs can manage
much more severe pain
then endorphins can opioid receptors
also influence everything from mood to
normal bodily functions with these
functions to opioids binding strength
and durability mean their effects are
more pronounced and widespread than
those of the body's natural signaling
molecules when a drug binds to opioid
receptors it triggers the release of
dopamine which is linked to feelings of
pleasure and may be responsible for the
sense of euphoria that characterizes an
opioid high at the same time
opioids suppress the release of
noradrenaline which influences
wakefulness breathing digestion and
blood pressure a therapeutic dose
decreases noradrenaline enough to cause
side effects like constipation at higher
doses opioids can decrease heart and
breathing rates to dangerous levels
causing loss of consciousness and even
death over time the body starts to
develop a tolerance for opioids it may
decrease its number of opioid receptors
or the receptors may become less
responsive to experience the same
release of dopamine and resulting mood
effects as before people have to take
larger and larger doses a cycle that
leads to physical dependence and
addiction as people take more opioids to
compensate for tolerance noradrenaline
levels become lower and lower to a point
that could impact basic bodily functions
the body compensates by increasing its
number of noradrenaline receptors so it
can detect much smaller amounts of
noradrenaline this increased sensitivity
to noradrenaline allows the body to
continue functioning normally in fact it
becomes dependent on opioids to maintain
the new balance when someone who is
physically dependent on opioids stops
taking them abruptly that balance is
disrupted nor adrenaline levels can
increase within a day of ceasing opioid
use but the body takes much longer to
get rid of all the extra noradrenaline
receptors it made that means there's a
period of time when the body is too
sensitive to noradrenaline
this over sensitivity causes withdrawal
symptoms including muscle aches stomach
pains fever and vomiting though
temporary opioid withdrawal can be
incredibly debilitating in serious cases
someone in withdrawal can be violently
ill for days or even weeks people who
are addicted to opioids aren't
necessarily using the drugs to get high
anymore
but rather to avoid being sick many risk
losing wages or even jobs while in
withdrawal or may not have anyone to
take care of them during withdrawal if
someone goes back to using opioids later
they can be at particularly high risk
for overdose because what would have
been a standard dose while their
tolerance was high can now be lethal
since 1980 accidental deaths from opioid
overdose have grown exponentially in the
United States and opioid addictions have
also exploded around the world while
opioid painkiller prescriptions are
becoming more closely regulated cases of
overdose and addiction are still
increasing especially among younger
people many of the early cases of
addiction were middle-aged people who
became addicted to painkillers they had
been prescribed or received from friends
and family members with prescriptions
today young people are often introduced
to prescription opioid drugs in those
ways but move on to heroin or illicit
synthetic opioids that are cheaper and
easier to come by beyond tighter
regulation of opioid painkillers what
can we do to reverse the growing rates
of addiction and overdose a drug called
naloxone is currently our best defense
against overdose naloxone binds to
opioid receptors but doesn't activate
them it blocks other opioids from
binding to the receptors and even knocks
them off the receptors to reverse an
overdose opioid addiction is rarely a
standalone illness frequently people
with opioid dependence are also
struggling with a mental health
condition there are both inpatient and
outpatient programs that combine
medication health services and
psychotherapy
but many of these programs are very
expensive and the more affordable
options can have long waiting lists they
also often require complete
detoxification from opioids before
beginning treatment both the withdrawal
period and the common months long stay
in a facility can be impossible for
people who risk losing jobs and housing
in that time frame opioid maintenance
programs aim to address some of these
obstacles and eliminate opioid abuse
using a combination of medication and
behavior therapy these programs avoid
withdrawal symptoms with drugs that bind
to opioid receptors but don't have the
psychoactive effects of painkillers
heroin and other commonly abused opioids
methadone and buprenorphine are the
primary opioid maintenance drugs
available today but doctors need a
special waiver to prescribe them even
though no specific training or
certification is required to prescribe
opioid painkillers buprenorphine can be
so scarce that there's even a growing
black market for it there's still a long
way to go with combating opioid
addiction but there are great resources
for making sense of the treatment
options if you or someone you know is
struggling with opioid use in the United
States the Department of Health and
Human Services operates a helpline 806
six two four three five seven and a
database of more than 14,000 substance
abuse facilities in the US ww HHS gov
slash opioids